ACCOUNTABLE AND AMERICA'S
PROBLEMS WILL GET WORSE AND
WORSE -- YOU THINK THE ECONOMY
IS BAD NOW.
BUCKLE UP.
WITH DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE, IT
WILL IMPLODE.
IT WILL GET WORSE.
HERE WITH MORE CHARLES PAYNE.
THIS ELECTION IS LIKE A BOAT
TAKING ON WATER.
FIRST YOU HAVE TO PLUG UP THE
HOLE.
HOPEFULLY THIS PLUGS UP THE
I DON'T SEE IN JOE BIDEN WHETHER
WE SAW IN BILL CLINTON:
THE ABILITY TO ADAPT TO
POLITICAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
PUBLIC OPINION.
DO YOU SEE THAT IN JOE BIDEN?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IN FACT, JOE BIDEN HAS COME IN
WITH A SINGULAR PLAN, THE
CLIMATE CHANGE AGENDA.
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE EVERY
TIME THERE IS A CONVERSATIONS
LIKE QUESTIONS DURING A PRESS
CONFERENCE, THEY WRAP IT IN THE
VENEER OF ECONOMICS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE THING THAT
MATTERS.
THAT'S THE GREEN AGENDA.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IS PAYING
A SERIOUS PRICE.
YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW MUCH WORSE
IT WILL GET.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE KNOW.
THAT'S SELDOM REPORTED.
WHEN WE GO FURTHER INTO THIS
CRUDE OIL PROBLEM.
DIESEL IS USED FOR TRUCKS AND
TRAINS AND JET PLANES.
THAT COMMERCIAL INVENTORY IS AT
THE LOWEST LEVEL SINCE 1951!
CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW MUCH IT'S
GOING TO COST NOW TO BRING
PRODUCE FROM A FARM TO A HOME OR
BRING GOODS FROM A FACTORY TO
A STORE.
>> Sean: CHARLES, I TALKED TO
FARMERS ON MY RADIO SHOW OFTEN.
THEY TELL ME THE COST OF
FERTILIZER QUADRUPLED AND THE
COST OF SEEDS DOUBLED.
AND THE COST OF SPARE PARTS FOR
EQUIPMENT IS TRIPLE WHAT THEY
PAID 2 YEARS AGO.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING.
TO KEEP THEIR FARMS OPEN THEY
HAVE TO CHARGE MORE AND IT COSTS
MORE TO SHIP IT TO WHEREVER IT'S
GOING.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER PART.
THE WAR AND FOSSIL FUELS
INCLUDES NATURAL GUESS.
WHAT ABOUT CORN?
CORN IS FUEL.
IF YOU MAKE CORN EXPENSIVE IT
COSTS MORE TO FEED THE
LIVESTOCK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK LIVE POULTLY
PRICES ARE THROUGH THE ROOF?
IT'S ALL CONNECTED.
IT'S SO NUTS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE -- POULTRY.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE POLITICAL
SKILLS OF BILL CLINTON WHO WOULD
FEEL YOUR PAIN AND COULD PIVOT.
IF THEY WIN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE THIS IS JUST THE WARM UP
ACT.
NO ONE THOUGHT YOU COULD SAY I
WILL DO 3 $60 BILLION ON
A CLIMATE BILL -- EVEN PEOPLE
WHO WORKED WITH THAT STUFF.
SOMEBODY SAID I WAS USED TO
TAKING IN BILLION DOLLARS.
-- MILLION DOLLARS.
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BILLION
DOLLARS.
IT'S NUTS.
>> Sean: THEY SAID IN NEW
ENGLAND THIS WINTER THEY MAY
HAVE BLACKOUTS BECAUSE NOT
ENOUGH NATURAL GAS TO KEEP THE
GRID AT THE LEVEL THEY NEED.
A GENERAL SAID THEY ARE ONLY
GETTING 1/10th OF ACTUAL
SUPPLIES FOR NEW ENGLAND TO HEAT
THEIR HOMES THIS WINTER.
WHAT DO WE DO AT THAT POINT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS GAME TO
PLAY.
TO WIN AN ELECTION.
THIS IS SO UNFAIR TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC TO SET US UP IN
THIS POSITION.
HOME HEATING OIL WILL BE
EXPENSIVE IF YOU CAN GET IT.
FOOD PRICES WILL GO THROUGH THE
ROOF.
THEY ARE DRAWING DOWN THE
PETROLEUM RESERVE IS ONE OF THE
MOST IRRESPONSIBLE ACT THE
PRESIDENT COULD DO.
THEY ARE DOING THIS TO ATTEMPT
TO WIN THE MID-TERM ELECTIONS.
WHEN THOSE ELECTIONS ARE OVER
AND WINTER SETS IN AMERI